this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out Squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit here in the
21st century capitalism is an
increasingly controversial word there's
a growing conversation about how much we
should trust obscenely wealthy people
and whether or not there should be upper
limits placed on human wealth regardless
of where you stand on modern day
captains of industry the landscape looks
nothing like it did a hundred and fifty
years ago compared to now the days of
the robber barons were the Wild West
both figuratively and literally across
Europe and North America the late 19th
century was a time of industrialization
and ingenuity and it led to the world's
inaugural class of independently uber
wealthy businessman up until the 1800s
it had been exceedingly rare any one
individual to amass huge piles of riches
without ever sitting on a throne that is
until industrialized economies began to
reward men not for wholesomeness or
morality but for shrewd calculations and
doing whatever was necessary very few
men distinguished themselves in these
pursuits like today's protagonist he
took a successful family business and
built it into a three-headed empire that
still helps underwrite the world even
100 years after his death he spent
decades financing the major projects and
players of the Industrial Revolution on
both sides of the Atlantic Ocean when
governments ran out of money
he didn't his name is JP Morgan and he
paid for the world that you're living in
today
[Music]
John Pierpont Morgan was born into about
as good a situation as anyone could hope
for his paternal grandfather Joseph
Morgan was one of the founders of
Connecticut's Aetna insurance company a
successful venture that grew and evolved
over the decades and was most recently
bought by CVS health corporation in 2017
for 69 billion dollars Morgan's father
Junius was a successful businessman in
his own right before the birth of his
children he worked as a partner at JM
beeban company a significant New England
dry goods importer that doubled as one
of the largest retailers in Boston he
would eventually leave his jobs you take
an even more glamorous position as the
business partner a famous financier and
London philanthropist George Peabody
Morgan's mother was Juliette Pierpont's
the daughter of noted Connecticut poet
John Pierpont it was best known for his
poem the heirs of Palestine but also
worked as a teacher and Unitarian
minister to all that is quite the
preamble to the birth of the eldest
Morgan Charles John Pierpont Morgan who
was born on April the 17th 1837 and he
very much enjoyed the fruits of a
privileged New England childhood he was
a sickly boy who suffered from coughs
and seizures however when he felt
healthy enough he would attend concerts
and art shows in the Northeast
he enjoyed outings with his parents
where he told everyone that he liked to
be called by his middle name Pierpont at
age 11 he enrolled at the forerunner to
Connecticut's prestigious Cheshire
Academy where he was allowed to board
with the school's principal
three years later he smashed the
entrance exam for Boston's English high
school a school that specifically
catered toward mathematically inclined
students who were looking for a career
in Business and Finance he matriculated
there in the fall of 1851 at the age of
his father was grooming him for the
family business unfortunately before he
could finish his first year at the
English high school young Pierpont's was
struck with another medical malady
Pierpont was incapacitated by a
devastating bout of rheumatic fever just
as an untreated cold or flu might evolve
into a more serious case of pneumonia
rheumatic fever is the occasional
escalation
an untreated throat infection according
to the encyclopedia of infectious
diseases rheumatic fever only afflicts
about 3% of streptococcal infections but
it is more common in young children
between the ages of 5 to 14 ironically
the disease most often afflicts
impoverished people because of a lack of
proper nutrition and hygiene pierre pons
he was already less healthy than the
average boy his age was completely
sidelined by the illness thus his father
Jr's did what any father would do for a
sick child he sent him to live by
himself in the azure islands in the
North Atlantic Ocean mr. Morgan believes
that the salty air of the Portuguese
arse which helped Pierpont's recover
from his condition ultimately he stayed
on the islands for nearly a year
when pierpon su was finally well enough
to return to the United States and
finish his secondary education he felt
invigorated by his relatively clean bill
of health he graduated from the English
high school quickly earning a rewards of
well just more school with his Boston
education completed Junius next sent
Pierpont's to bella reeve school in the
cozy swiss town of Latour pleased just
across from Lake Geneva from the French
border here he picked up a valuable
fluency in French which his father
believed would be hugely beneficial to a
future business magnate like Pierpont's
once it mastered French conjuncture
Pierpont's moved to Germany's University
of göttingen where he mastered his third
language in less than a year whilst
there he also formalized his love of art
many of us might have loathed much of
the artistic exposure that was forced
upon us as young children but evidently
parents couldn't get enough he left
Germany with an additional degree in art
history with his formal education
finally rounded out pip on whence he
meets his father in London by the mid
1950s juniors had taken that partnership
with George Peabody
thus when his son was ready to enter the
workforce in 1857 the London branch of
Peabody borgin & Company was the most
logical place for a first job
Morgan worked in London for about a year
before returning to New England
Junius trust and his son as a reliable
business auxilary which is how Pierpont
landed a position as a clerk at new
york's duncan sherman and companies the
american representatives of peabody
morgan company even in his twenties
pierpon showed a keen nose for profits
one story from his early years recalls
how he bought coffee at a short price
off in New Orleans boat captain who
couldn't find any bars for his product
Morgan used the company's considerable
funds to buy the coffee then leveraged
his connections in the area to find
buyers that the ship captain never could
he sold the coffee at a significant rate
of return their bonds had only been in
New York for about a year when he fell
in love in 1859 while navigating the New
York art scene he met Amelia the
daughter of a wealthy arts patron named
Jonathan Sturges Amelia had her own
little nickname and like to be called
Mimi Mimi and her family were scheduled
to do some travelling in 1859 and a
veteran European traveler like Pierre
Ponce was just the expert they need it
he drew them up an itinerary that landed
in London then met them over in the Big
Smoke once they were finished people
spent two weeks with Mimi before
escorting her across the Atlantic back
to New York in the modern dating scene a
young single woman would probably feel
that Pierpont's was trying way too hard
but Mimi didn't seem to mind she agreed
to marry Pierre bombs in the following
year during the spring of 1868 823 it
was the happiest had ever been in his
young life unfortunately though there
were twin disasters right around the
corner the following Windsor in 1861
Mimi came down with a pesky cough that
just wouldn't go away at the same time
the American Civil War was just weeks
from exploding now you might think
mystery ailments would be easier to deal
with than your entire country breaking
out into armed conflict around to you
but Pierpont evaded service in the Union
Army by paying $300 to a substitute for
that matter so did eventual peers john d
rockefeller Andrew Carnegie Jay Gould
and James melon melons parts he felt
some guilt after the fact about avoiding
the war prompting his father to write to
him that a man may be a patriot without
asking his own life or sacrificing his
health there are plenty of lives less
valuable
we don't know where young pip on stood
on the value of his own life during the
first year of the Civil War what we do
know is that he desperately wanted to
find a cure for his coughing bride-to-be
after the pair was married in October of
1861 he recalled his own successful
recovery in the Azores a decade earlier
so he made plans to honeymoon with Mimi
and the rejuvenating climate of the
Mediterranean they set up a quaint
residence in Algeria
soon after while visiting France lung
specialists finally diagnosed Mimi's
illness she had tuberculosis air bombs
waited on her constantly hoping to
improve her condition
Nene actually wrote a letter to her
mother back in the States saying I wish
you could see his loving devoted care of
me he spares nothing for my comfort and
improvement sadly tuberculosis spared
very few people in the 19th century and
Mimi was no exception she died in
February 1862 four months after a
marriage to Morgan 24 years olds our
protagonist was already a widower pibil
dulse with the loss of his love by
throwing himself back into his work he
returns in New York where he had already
made quite the name for himself as a
financier in 1860 Pepin's had broken
away from Duncan Sherman and company
where he had clerked two years and began
representing his father's firm in
America via his own eponymous firm J
Pierpont Morgan & Company the biggest
splash he was attached to was something
of a scandal after his engagement to
Mimi but before their marriage and
Mediterranean retreat Pierpont's it
helps finance a nasty bit of war
profiteering which became known as the
whole carbine affair the affair sees a
lot of money and a lot of guns change
hands and can be a bit confusing but the
simplified version goes something like
this Morgan was a part of a small
consortium called the Union Defense
League alongside two gentlemen named
Simon Stevens and Arthur Eastman Eastman
bought 5000 surplus Hall carbine rifles
from the US government which were
considered antiquated and too old for
use because of their age and the cow
of their rifling eastman border rifles
for $3.50 pop financed by Morgan's money
in August of 1861 the rifles were almost
immediately sold back to Major General
John Fremont and the US government more
than six hundred percent of their
original cost $22 a rifle the sale was
made under the assumption that the
rifling had been adjusted to government
standard 58 caliber the parties
exchanged guns and money but the Morgan
consortium hadn't held up their end of
the bargain the rear breaching chambers
where infantry would load 58 caliber
ammunition into the back of the weapon
had been adequately adjusted however the
actual rifling of the weapons remains in
compatibly sized over the course of the
Civil War many infantryman blames these
old defective Holkar lines for terrible
misfires and accidents many of which led
to self-inflicted injuries and
potentially preventable amputations
almost immediately there was a US
congressional investigation
Major General Fremont who purchased the
guns had boss and that guy complained to
his boss who complained to the Secretary
of War and the next thing you know the
whole carbine affair was born the
criticism was blistering newspapers ran
dramatic muckraking headlines at one
point the Congressional Committee on
government contracts issued a statement
proclaiming worse than the traitors in
arms are the men who pretends loyalty to
the flag feast and fatten on the
misfortunes of the nation while Patriot
blood is crimsoning the plains of the
south and the bodies of their countrymen
are moldering in the dust much of this
criticism was refuted years later by e
gordon Lassen's 1940s investigation the
whole carbine affair a study in
contemporary folklore
what isn't refutable is that Morgan had
made a small fortune off of the deal the
new injection of capital financed
several of the projects he busied
himself with following the death of Mimi
Pierre Ponce went full throttle for his
father's company until 1864 it was then
that George Peabody his father's old
partner decided to retire George Peabody
& Co was rebranded as jeaious Morgan &
Co perhaps to avoid confusion between
two similarly sounding firms Pippins
took an opportunity to partner with
senior Charles age Dabney whom he knew
from his European haunts in order to
reform his own house as Dabney Morgan &
Co now with all these banking firms
forming and reforming you might be
wondering just what is it that
Pierpont's actually did and it's a fair
question much of what he did was act as
an American agent for his london-based
father but he did a fair amount of his
own investment as well early on he
traded mostly in government bonds and
foreign exchange but as the 1860s went
on he began leveraging his international
contacts to connect all European money
with new American industrialists so is
the civil war concluded and American
reconstruction gave way to
industrialization in the Gilded Age no
one on earth became more adept at
linking railroad barons and aspiring
inventors with deep reservoirs of
investment capital early in his career
Pierpont's was often a mere facilitator
connecting finance seers and visionaries
for a small cut of the profits but as
the century wore on Morgan a master
larger and larger fortune and became
wealthy enough and powerful enough to
finance many of these projects on his
own now you might not be financing a
railroad across the country but maybe
you want to start your own business and
maybe you've got an idea for a business
knocking around in your head and well
you're never gonna know if that's a
great idea for a business unless you get
it out there in the world and a great
way to do that is with a website from
Squarespace now it's obviously pretty
scary to go out there and try new things
launching a business is a whole big deal
it's kind of scary but not knowing how
to set up a website should not be an
excuse for not doing it there are no
excuses available with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website for whatever you're up
to online you want to sell something
absolutely they do stores you want to do
a podcast they handle that too now it
all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that you can just
customize to your heart's content
or you can start from scratch or you can
easily move over from an existing domain
making everything super easy to manage
but I own star from scratch just use a
template
no excuses and once you've gone through
the super easy customization process
there are no updates no patches low-tech
PS they have to deal where them
Squarespace also handles all of that web
sweetie stuff podcasts yes mailing lists
yes social integrations yes and not more
like I say Squarespace removes your
excuses and getting to your dreams so
just do it
also 24/7 customer support if you get
stuck but you probably won't because
it's easy to use app - Squarespace comm
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com or would
slash buyer graphics and you'll save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain and let's get back to it in the
aftermath of the Civil War pair Ponce
had two major life developments first he
remarried his new wife was Francis
Louisa Tracy another woman he had met in
his high-class social circle in New York
she too had a nickname and preferred to
be called Fanny Fanny was not Pierpont's
one true love like many of the American
power brokers who came after him
Pierpont preferred long intense hours of
grinding out work brokering meetings and
traveling abroad Fanny was completely
his opposite she was a homebody he
preferred to spend her time with
children and close friends despite their
ink VAT ability the two remained married
until after Morgan's death nearly 50
years later they had four children
Louisa John Pierpont jr. Juliet and Anne
by the birth of his youngest daughter
and in 1873 Pierpont's professional life
was ready to evolve as well his new
partner Dabney retired in 1871 so Morgan
formed a new partnership with the
powerful Drexel family of Philadelphia
you should probably have this formula
down by now so it likely won't surprise
you to learn that their new joint
banking venture was called Drexel Morgan
& Company years later when Antony Drexel
died the firm was rechristened as
something that might sound familiar to
modern audiences JP Morgan & Co for the
next 20 years Morgan's career seemed
powered by rocket fuel no longer a meal
wealthy financier living in his powerful
father's shadow
JP Morgan began shaping the numerous
railroad conglomerates that were
exploding across the American landscape
a few simple loans were enough to keep
the coffers full but Morgan did much
more than that he positioned himself at
the center of any number of mergers and
reorganizations growing both his power
and his portfolio one of Morgan's
earliest moves in the railroad sector
was seizing a relatively small line
called Albany and Susquehanna from
robber barons Jay Gould and Jim Fisk in
1869 Gould and Fisk has hatched a plan
to take a controlling interest in the
railroad by buying a majority stake
Joseph Ramsey the president of the
railroad blocked their attempts by
issuing thousands of new shares to his
supporters incensed by the move Gould
and Fisk turned to more nefarious
methods pressuring a crooked judge to
issue arrest warrants for president
Ramsey at one point Fisk literally gone
our train and rode through several
Alberni and Susquehanna Line stations
beating up rail workers and attempt to
intimidate the company and submission
the only thing that stopped him was a
railroad employee who pretended to be a
police officer arrested Fisk and took
him to jail when he was eventually
released
visca did the same thing all over again
culminating in a massive railway Bruhl
that had to be broken up by the state
militia all of this madness ended with
JP Morgan sensing an opportunity and
sweeping in with a $500,000 mortgage
payments Morgan talked his way into
stewardship of the railroad he was
elected vice president of the company
and controller of the road
six months later he leased it to the
Delaware and Hudson railroad company for
four hundred and ninety thousand dollars
a year the lease ran for ninety nine
years Morgan was already well-off from
his family's wealth and his early career
moves but his involvement with the
railroads made him obscenely rich for
decades he scoured the exploding
railroad industry for opportunities and
it rarely disappointed him in 1879 for
example railroad magnate William
Vanderbilt approached him asking for
help in the sale of $250,000 in stock
shares for the New York Central Railroad
he sold all of it without dropping the
share price by a $1 which scored in the
seat on the railways Board of Directors
in 1880 he was the center
figure in ass in Dakota that made a 40
million dollar bond sale to finance the
highly anticipated Northern Pacific
Railway up to that point it was the
largest transaction of railroad bonds in
US history in 1885 he restructured the
New York West Shore and Buffalo railroad
company then leased it to Vanderbilt New
York Central he made similar moves in
Pennsylvania Virginia and Ohio as
Morgan's personal fortune grew so did
his clout as a captain of industry in
1882 he moved his family to a prominent
brownstone mansion at 219 Madison Avenue
three blocks from where the Empire State
Building would eventually be built he
was a recognizable face around New York
City not just because of his
metaphorical stature in the finance
world but also because of his literal
countenance Morgan was tall and
broad-shouldered with a great bushy
mustache and as he grew into middle-age
his face was actually becoming deformed
among the maladies that Morgan suffered
from was recession a chronic skin
condition that swells and Redden's much
of the tissue around the nose and cheeks
Morgan's rosacea was coupled with
rhinophyma the developments of a huge
overgrown bulbous nose which often
brings inflammation pimples and papules
the combination of Morgan's size
aggression and facial features made him
a truly intimidating man to be around
other Titans of the Gilded Age carried a
reputation for cutthroat tendencies but
Morgan actually looked the part to make
matters worse he was often photographed
because of his fame but he hated to be
photographed because he was
self-conscious about his appearance his
anger at being photographed only served
to heighten his naturally intimidating
profile it was a vicious cycle one that
only served to make him more
intimidating and distrusted by the
public as his wealth kept growing by the
time that Junius Morgan passed away in
1890 his son had become one of the
wealthiest and most powerful men in the
world Morgan had amassed such a
combination of money and power that he
was almost single-handedly responsible
for navigating the United States economy
out of the panic of 1893 back when the
US dollar was backed by gold a financial
downturn
could wipe out the National gold
reserves that's precisely what happens
in the final years of the 19th century
as the u.s. recoiled under a mountain of
financial pressure Morgan called a
meeting with US President Grover
Cleveland
he offered to replenish the US coffers
from his own banks the US government
resisted at first exploring the idea of
selling bonds to the public but
ultimately obtained 3.5 million ounces
of gold from a trust headed by Morgan in
return the US government issued 30-year
bonds Morgan saved the Treasury but in
doing so he armed the Democratic Party
with one of its chief complaints in the
upcoming election of 1896 William
Jennings Bryan skewered the cozy
relationship between Republicans and
wildly powerful banks like JP Morgan &
Company Brian's point was both right and
moot when Morgan and several of his
banker friends donated heavily to the
campaign of Republican nominee William
McKinley who won in 1896 and again in
1900 life was good for JP Morgan he
smoked Cuban cigars all day every day
and purchased fine art wherever he could
find it he was grooming his only son
John Pierpont Jr's who joined the Morgan
Banking Empire just as his father once
did for him his eldest daughter Louisa
married a lawyer named Herbert Satterly
who was on track to become assistant
secretary of the Navy another daughter
Juliette married a man named William
Pierson Hamilton a descendent of
Alexander Hamilton as the 20th century
approached life in the house of Morgan
was very very good Morgan became the
president of the Metropolitan Museum of
Art and was also a prominent leader in
the Episcopal Church he spends a great
deal of time collecting rare gemstones
and part of his collection was displayed
at the World's Fair in Paris in 1889 and
somehow in between all that and all the
banking work he was a frequent and
passionate yata Morgan loved to sail
after decades of grinding out work he
likely saw a good retreat on one of his
yachts as a well-earned rest bite one
infamous story from the house of Morgan
recounts how a socialite friends of his
once asked how much the maintenance on
his yacht cost Morgan allegedly replied
that if you have to ask you can't afford
it thus a truly American
syllogism was born in his later years
Morgan certainly had interests to enjoy
but it didn't mean he wasn't still
working
he helps fund Thomas Edison's initial
experiments with electricity and later
helped inform General Electric
separately in 1898 JP Morgan & Co
financed the creation of federal Steel
two years later he began negotiating
with Andrew Carnegie and Charles Schwab
to buy Carnegie's steel business in the
hopes of merging it with other smaller
companies together those acquisitions as
well as his own creation could form one
massive conglomerate that succeeded via
superior logistics and infrastructure
the result was the United States Steel
Corporation and in 1901 it was awarded a
market capitalization of 1.4 billion
dollars making it the world's first
billion-dollar company around the same
time Morgan teamed up with Canadian
American railroad executive James Hill
to create another new corporation the
northern securities company this was a
holding company designed to holds in the
majority shares in Northern Pacific
Great Northern and see B&Q railroads
this gave Morgan control of one third of
all US railways now in the aftermath of
the Sherman Antitrust law of 1890 Morgan
was careful to avoid moves that could be
seen as subverting fair market
competition he would even go so far as
to directly check with the US presidents
on the legality and fairness of
potential acquisitions before buying or
restructuring anything but the northern
securities company is where Morgan
finally pushed his luck just a bit too
far his friends and Ally President
William McKinley had been assassinated
by an anarchist in September of 1901 he
was replaced by Vice President Teddy
Roosevelt's headstrong populist and avid
trust Buster who had a much less chummy
relationship with America's biggest
banker Roosevelt wasted no time in using
the Sherman Antitrust law to break up
the northern securities company in 1902
thus Morgan waged a drawn-out legal
battle with Roosevelt and his government
even though he suspected the law wasn't
on his side as soon as the Justice
Department at sued him the US Supreme
Court upheld Roosevelt's decision two
years later in 1904 Morgan remains angry
with Roosevelt for the remainder of his
life
didn't stop him from helping the federal
government when it needed it during the
panic of 1907 the US economy was once
again in dire straits several key banks
were on the brink of collapse so Morgan
did what he did best he leveraged his
considerable political power to get as
many wealthy friends into one room as he
could and then he commanded them when
where and how to spend their money to
stop the panic he used his influence to
secure otherwise unavailable lines of
credit then bought up tons of devalued
stock to inject much-needed capital back
into the economy even scored a revenge
win over Roosevelt the story is
convoluted but Morgan was put in a
position where he could save the US
economy by spending 30 million dollars
to purchase stock in a company called
Tennessee : iron which was a chief
competitor of his company u.s. steel by
the letter of the law the move violated
the Sherman Antitrust Act but Roosevelt
had no recourse but to allow the
purchase the panic ended days later
despite his stabilizing efforts during
the panic of 1907 JP Morgan was all but
retired 50 years of Starks and steel and
imperfect howls that left him tired and
out of energy understandably he wanted
to enjoy his yachts and his art so he
spent the final years of his life at sea
and in leisure supporting many of the
New York artists that he enjoyed and
sailing to new parts of the world in
1911 the avid ship lover was excited to
take his place on the maiden voyage of
the Titanic the Titanic was operated by
the White Star Line which was owned by a
Morgan Corporation the international
Mercantile Marine company the chain of
ownership Minh Morgan had his own
private suite and promenade deck on the
ship at the very last minute though he
decided to cancel his attendance on the
maiden voyage due to health reasons
choosing to remain at a resort in the
French Alps after the ship sank he
remarked monetary losses amount to
nothing in life it is the loss of life
that counts it's certainly a credible
opinion from a man who appeared to have
all the money in the world
Morgan outlived the Titanic but not by
much his health began to deteriorate in
1913 he died while visiting Rome on
March the 31st 1913 he was
two weeks shy of his 76th birthday
Morgan's legacy as both a banker and a
philanthropist is a powerful one
his personal estate was worth sixty
eight point three million dollars at the
time of his death in today's money that
would make him a billionaire much of his
art was either donated to the Mets or
preserved in what is now New York's
Morgan Library and Museum we could
probably do an entire video just on
Morgan's art collection which was worth
tens of millions of dollars even back
then as for JP Morgan & Co his son took
over the family business after his death
the company included Morgan's original
business enterprises well this is
father's London Enterprise that Morgan
eventually took over after the old man's
death
the London company was restructured
shortly before Morgan's death as Morgan
Grenfell and cope it remained tied to
its sister companies in the US until the
1980s it became Deutsche Bank in 1990 as
for the US side of things JP Morgan & Co
was forced to split itself by the
glass-steagall Act of 1933 which forced
banks to separate their commercial and
investment elements JP Morgan & Company
stayed on the commercial side eventually
becoming JP Morgan Chase at the turn of
the 21st century the speculative side of
JP Morgan morphed into Morgan Stanley in
1935 that means that JP Morgan over the
course of 75 years engineered the
creation of three of the 21st century's
most prominent banks and even that
arguably wasn't his greatest
accomplishment his repeated support of
troubled banks failing businesses and a
panicked US government prompted the
creation of the US Federal Reserve in
the aftermath of the panic of 1907 it
was clear that the US government could
no longer operate without a federal
banking system that could better control
the flow of money throughout the economy
it was too risky to rely on the timely
support of a few ultra wealthy power
brokers to resolve recessions six years
later during the same year the Morgan
died the u.s. created the Federal
Reserve
despite momentous public backlash the
Federal Reserve was a necessary action
the United States could never again
allow itself to rely on an ultra wealthy
power broker that could single-handedly
put the economy back together again
all that was unlikely is that there
would ever be another man like JPMorgan
so I really hope you found their video
interesting if you did please do smash
that like button below and do not forget
to subscribe also check out our
fantastic sponsor Squarespace link to
below and thank you for watching
[Music]